with uh that incident with japan i don't
know
unfortunately you know i was leaving out
and then i just seen
some popcorn on top of my head you know
to be um honest man this [ __ ] is getting
out of hand especially for me
um just the amount of disrespect the
amount of
just fans just doing whatever the [ __ ]
they want to do
it's just it's out of pocket man it's
out of pocket seriously like
in the other setting you know i'm all
for the fans to join the game and
having fun and you know it's part of
sports
i get it but there's a certain thing
that crossed the line
and any other setting i know for a fact
that fans and they wouldn't come up
a guy wouldn't come on the street and
pour popcorn on my head because
he know what happened a guy wouldn't
come up to me and
talk mess about my kids and family on
the street because
the response will be different in these
arenas you got to start protecting the
players minute
you know we'll see what the nba does but
the you know
there's a huge consequence for us as
players and
especially for me i've been in a lot of
incidents where fans
they say whatever um and
the consequences for me are a lot more
detrimental
than to those people in the stands
because they feel like they're
untouchable
um they can stay what they want they're
at a sporting event where they should
enjoy the game
but a lot of times fans don't realize
it's our job this is my job this is not
some play this is what uh something i
love to do this is something i love
competing at
so to get food thrown on top of me um
it's just [ __ ]
really um and if i you know
unfortunately you know i couldn't get to
the stands but
i just don't i just don't take that
lightly i don't
you know to me it happens to me a lot of
times and
you know obviously i've learned to kind
of look the other way but after a
certain extent you can't just keep
looking all the way
there has to be some penalties or
something
to put in place where fans can't just
come to the games and do and say
as they please because they wouldn't do
that [ __ ] anywhere else any other
setting and
i'm sick and tired of it honestly